welcome everyone to the lecture tonight
we're going to talk about Olympia and
today was a great day for the US team
u.s. defeated Ukraine two and half to
one and half thanks to the victory by
Fabiano Caruana and Ukraine actually
been playing fantastic so far they
defeated Russia and the next round they
defeated China so sort of now they had
to if they head down well against the US
team they play the top three seeds but
the good news is US team won this match
in a very close battle three draws and
Fabiano karana won the game so and I
will show you the game and you'll see
now how he managed that in this kind of
matchups it's very important to win one
game and just not to lose on the other
boards because you know it so that's all
what you need two and a half out of four
to win the match and you get two points
so you've trained got no points for
losing the match you guys got two points
so now India is leading with a perfect
score six out of six and tomorrow USA
was playing with them so it's going to
be very exciting to see how this match
is gonna unfold so but let's take a look
at this game and we'll talk about this
match here efore c5 Fabiano the opponent
is pavel a leonov very strong run a
ukrainian grandmaster over 2700 very
solid player and he plays a Sicilian
defense this should be 5 so Khurana
doesn't go for the mainlines with
default it plays for this setup
rosalie mo the name of the setup is now
g6 Bishop takes c6 b takes c6 also
Bishop g7 and now rook e1 yes
you can also play D takes at six you
know it's just he wants to play this
line I mean both homes are playable one
you just daily two different type of
positions here black wants to have more
pawns in the center and he has a pair of
the bishops nine th six this is a
typical way to develop the knight here
because if you develop the knight on f6
it's going to get hit by b5 so you go
Knight h6
C three castles h3 the point of this
move is to control the g4 squared to
prevent a knight or a bishop here from
coming here and of course this will also
give the King an important lift for the
later on the game so it's important to
do this f5 by le on a very concrete move
here when you have two bishops what you
need to do open the position and this
way he wants to bring his knight into
the game as well Caruana plays d5 when
you have two knights you want to close
the position keep it closed right 9 f7 d
3c d 4 looks natural but in that case
again we see some simplifications
happening ok and position will position
will open up as well ok so that's why he
played the move d3 just to keep the
position closed rugby 8 why is he
playing rook da th who can explain me
the idea behind this move because it
looks like he might be able to do
something else but what is the idea deep
idea behind this move here yes excellent
thinking yes he is simply putting
pressure on the pawn on b2 and that way
now Bishop cannot move from c1 a bishop
moves you simply take the pawn on if you
so he is trying to keep this Bishop
doing some defensive work Knight 83 I
think it's a good move because now he
wants to bring the knight on c4 at some
point
Bishop a6 I think black lit really well
actually and I think he equalized the
game at some point
after Bush base six so now this Bishop
is cutting off this night-night c4
nothing better than to do here just to
try to get the knight in Bishop c4 black
has the advantage of two bishops but
position is kind of close here so he
thought this is a good opportunity to
simplify the position okay
take end d6 he is trying to open the
position and get rid of this ePHI pawn
again Caruana doesn't have time for
Bishop f4 because of the b2 pawn is
hanging and he opted for this movie six
to keep it close I think if it takes he
probably didn't see any way to get an
advantage here so probably purchase pawn
takes and Queen d7 rook e8 block is just
very comfortable you want to be able to
press with white in this kind of
matchups you know in the team events you
want to get a position where you can
press so ii 595 i ileana takes takes
with the night with the bishop and now
Bishop h6 activating his bishop putting
pressure on the rook Bishop g7 came take
take now be to pawn it's hanging and he
could not take on b2 here because he
would have dropped the rook so that's
why I take take group b1 I think black
is doing more or less fine here this
pawn only six it's it's a little bit
weird it's hard to evaluate whether or
not this is actually a strength or a
weakness because if we take the Queen's
off the board now black will be much
better because they say every six fun is
a clear liability issue but with the
Queens on the board some potential
threats can happen so it's hard to say
who is better here I think it's pretty
balanced so this Queen if I move creates
little bit weaknesses and now he was
attacking the pawn on e6 rookie three
Queen 86 now he is attacking the pawn on
c4 b3 by car wanna Queen c8 now
attacking the pawn quit II won very deep
move because if you play Queen e2 black
is going to play a 5 anyway and then you
don't have any brakes so he anticipates
that then after a 5 he's going to play a
5 his opponent here white only has one
plum left in a position because he is
dealing with this weakness he is dealing
with this weakness actually computers
they were showing that's completely
equal disposition it wouldn't give any
advantage when I start watching the game
live around 8:30 a.m. in the morning it
didn't look that great for us because
you know we were slightly worse on the
fourth board Shanklin coro coro
Beauchamp and we were slightly worse
here it looked like equal and Hikaru was
down upon against ponomaryov and on a
third-world Wesley didn't have anything
it was just a complete equal so we were
worse on both 2 & 4 and this looked kind
of balance it didn't really look that
optimistic I thought probably 2 2 is the
best we can get but things happen these
happen in these team events and we
managed to help the bed positions and
squeeze the maximum squeeze the maximum
to win the match so Ukraine probably was
very disappointed because it didn't look
like they're going to lose this match
you know they had some advantages on the
white boards and this didn't look that
bad I mean here by looking at the
position it looks like white has this
weaknesses but Khurrana made the right
decision here he played b4
take take group before and it's it's
it's the funny thing about this position
is black would actually win the pond but
you get a very dangerous past pun I
would say so take and you just pushes it
it's tricky you wrap upon but you might
actually lose because how are you going
to stop this past fun from marching down
a board it's outside pause pause okay
that's the problem you don't have a
check Queen is doing his job perfectly
guarding everything and just you just
continue pushing it so this is actually
looks like this might be some serious
problems here it's possible to even
insert the check and then push maybe
this is even more precise okay so Eliana
went for this position and but he didn't
take because of this a path one so he
played okay I believe this is a correct
move Queen a one now pinning this rook
f4 yeah I think here here basically here
he started to a little bit drift you
know you know maybe there was some other
ways he could have played here I think
you know but he he played f4 but
actually created the weak pawn now
rookie for f3
but now g4 and now white is a very
serious threat of g5 attacking the
knight attacking the rook King to g1
King to g8 and the Queen comes back on
d1 that's f3 pawn became weak what I'm
thinking here the best thing for Ileana
was perhaps to just go King g8 here and
then threatening to win the spot
so this way I think he has better
chances to hold f4 cookie for g4 now
King goes on g8 Queen to d1 now karana
is trying to win the pawn on f3 rook
takes c6 Queen f3 and here it's really
clear that White has small but a stable
advantage why do you think why it has a
stable advantage here what are the
reasons yes outside passed pawn and his
King feels maybe better protected and
now White has to do black has to deal
with his weaknesses so he played Queen
c7 which is fine I really like the next
move here by Caruana here I think this
was a superb move here what did car
wanna play here okay that is just superb
here very nice move here because black
doesn't have that many weaknesses here
again he wants to create that second
weakness right second weakness he wants
to do
yes absolutely see if I Bravo see five
very powerful move now opening up the
position creating some wit diagonals and
now if you play d5 the problem is check
now simply rook b6 and taking your c6
pawn
and taking it okay if okay for it just
takes p7 pawn is very weak here as well
if you play Roxy that's a very passive
defense and that kind of defense not
going to succeed because then I go a six
accommodate about of p7 and just wins
the game
don't play passive defense usually when
opponent has a passed pawn in a file
passive defense not going to work so
very unpleasant position and they were
short on time but this sequence was
played excellently by Caruana
check he gave another check repeat a
little bit to gain some moves and take
the pawn this is already very serious
because now how many weaknesses block
has Q weaknesses and that's still there
right outside passed pawn so that's very
difficult now for block to do anything
here so he proposes the exchange of the
Queen's exchange of the Queen's will
really benefit black here so why should
an exchange in any circumstances here
Quincy three check Queen f6 Queen III I
mean this position is bad but I believe
his opponent really blundered in some
point here I'll show you what rook f8
rookie for now putting pressure on e7
look at seven rookie five I really like
this move because you cannot play this
move because of Queen e1 check so he
just simply shuts down the Queen and now
he is getting ready to put pushes pawn I
believe this maneuver on f7 is dubious
because it's not really going to help
the advance of this pawn anyway so I
think here he has a better way to defend
this position he must have a way to you
know it's not easy but there probably a
way for Y to defend a little bit better
here because rook on f7 I didn't like at
all now here past bounds meant to be
pushed yet that's what he's doing check
King g2
Queen a1 getting behind the passed pawn
queen e2
and now I'll play the movie 6 I'm not
sure about this is 6 month perhaps he
could maybe do something else here Betty
6 really weakens his position and also
but but he's trying to use a 7 trunk to
make his rook into yes when yeah if you
capture here can I can you take this guy
that's your most important pawn you're a
pawn if you're never immediate win here
it's going to be a draw I mean you can
get this position you can get enough
locks not better but you can get this
position but that's closer to draw than
a win ok so yeah it's really unpleasant
this rook on f7 so he played ecigs oh
sorry that's why he played Queen e2 so
you can play a6 pushing the pawn further
you push the pawn stronger it gets Queen
d4 I think somewhere here it's already
lost Queen takes rook takes is 6 now
karana is up a pawn on top of his
outside pass pawn c5 brookie 7 it's much
better to keep the Queen's on the board
here because this past pawn is further
advance with the rooks off the board he
can promote the spawn into a queen so
that's why it's better to do that
Ruki 7 check he calmly goes f3 no more
checks and this is the past pawn that is
going to bring the victory for white c4
Czech Queen B 2 was another way of
winning here was very strong as well but
I like this check and by the way if it
takes with a king white is a superb move
Queen e2
no checks whatsoever and just simply
push push
so you have to go away if
she said you go here check game is over
see through your queen is pinned
that's why we'll hear so I clean you so
you cannot place III so let's fight to
Queen f7 and now check centralizing the
Queen check can goes back g5 will lose
to a move like h4 and Queen g5 mates
check push past pounds and then to be
pushed last move by eliana of Queen g7
couldn't be 7 trying to defend and now
the last move here who is going to be
able to find the last move that force
the resignation at this moment all the
other games are finished so this wind
brought us the victory here probably
other ways to him but this was the best
way to finish the game here he's
basically made in his opponent with just
the king and queen and upon his meeting
the opponent now yes
h4 and remastered ilium of resigned
because of which idea c3 let's say I go
g5 can't go back because it's here so
has to go here beautiful checkmate see
you can even check mate with the Queen
and pawns in this position and if he
plays g5 Queen f7 checkmate excellent
very nice very nice victory they
interviewed car one after this game and
you know I mentioned that is very
delighted to win this game and this was
definitely his most important victory
for the US team so far I mean this is
his first event for the and he mentioned
that it will be very important to do
well in this tournament and try to win
the medals and possibly gold so
excellent excellent technique here so I
want to make sure we remember this
technique in endgame ok so I want to
leave this position here and make sure
you can finish it up from here opening
part was more or less balanced here but
after a 5 I think
Eliana 13 oh how could I be worse search
I'm pressuring him how could I really be
worse here b3 is week this week but this
before was a very good resource and so
how did he win this let's make sure
everybody here understand the plan here
that Caruana managed to squeeze and get
a win here what's the move here takes
take right here this F for f3 turn out
to be a bad idea because he end up
losing that F pawn so much better
defense is just King g8 back on pinning
the pin okay I think that probably would
offer impaired it still slightly worse
but I think it's a better try okay so
this a pawn is just causing the the
problems here and that's why he wanted
to get some activities but this turn out
to be an inaccuracy so now what do you
do
you have to pay active so remember that
your rook is being attacked what you're
going to do so stay active now you want
to take the pawn another strong move
g4 now threat is g5 he went here
yeah that's their really help block too
much because now he's going to likely
lose this pawn and even if it wins this
is going to be a cool material in other
case if he had done king Jade right away
then he would have keep the keep his he
wouldn't lose the F pawn now excellent
move rookie six Queen takes f3 correct
Queen c7 and now powerful moves if I
really like the way that color on a
plate here you show that he's picking up
his form here there were a couple of
shaky moments around before this he
could have lost some games some game
there but this game he played really
well you really squeeze the maximum it
was a crucial victory for the US team
because again around two and half hour
mark it didn't look like we're gonna win
this match you know try and control is
90 minutes 440 moves each half an hour
southern left so you know so it's a
start you looked at great for us we were
again slightly worse in some of the
matches and you know and this one looked
kind of vehicle but c5 is strong again
if he plays d5 how are we going to
proceed here
simply taking the pond oc6 okay winning
some ponds tags check
gaining some move you understand why he
repeated the position when you're a long
time you repeat the position to reach
move 40 ok so that way you can make the
time control you don't want to repeat
the position let's say if you have a lot
of time and your opponent is in time
trouble you only do that when you're a
long time ok so remember that don't just
do that because you've seen it look here
you do that so you can gain time do we
want to exchange Queens here if you do
that you're never going to win this game
you know and lose but you're not going
to win okay because the dynamics here is
that blocking is weaker then your King
check Queen f6 again if again if engine
was playing this position for black he
would never lose you know but for human
it's difficult to play I mean this
position is slightly better for white
not that much I mean it's better but
again it requires a very very precise
play which is very difficult to do
especially before the time controller
okay fade didn't quite like this rook f8
idea too much but it should is just very
unpleasant very very unpleasant here to
play but feels like the rook should stay
here to take care of this a 5-pound
advance you know
it's possible that even Queen could have
stayed there and just King g8 something
like this could be played I mean after
all it's equal material so it's not it
cannot be that terribly bad here I mean
it's slightly better for white maybe
King gee it was a world better but
really this idea was great regrouping
and now look if I need to move to shut
down the Queen and now this plan it also
stops the C pawn from advancing so it
goes Queen d6 a5
and place six yeah this is already more
or less decisive because II six pawn is
going to fall and f3
very good very good technique excellent
technique by karana to win this but
again we made some drawers yet I want to
show you this position also this is the
game this is the game he carves game
against ponomaryov okay let's get this
game so I want to get to the crucial
moment here so he cannot play the Benoni
defense okay yeah I wanna get to the
crush I don't want to spend anyway this
is a fourth line that supposed to be a
little bit better for white but usually
black makes a draw
okay this is all pretty much theory a
for rookie wine yeah so here I started
to watch the games like around here you
know at about two and a half hour mark
and it's clear that you know Hikaru is
fighting for a draw here down upon I
mean this was a long preparation I don't
know how deep but rookie for was played
apparently rookie rupee wants to gives
white some advantage we played here and
here I want you to find a way that you
played here because it's quite amazing
that he in a crucial situation like this
he just calmly calculated the
complications and went for this line it
looks like he could just lose the game
on the spot if he doesn't play like this
he's going to suffer for a long time and
maybe lose but by playing this making
just simply neutralize the white White's
extra point and and manage to just force
the drop yes
quindi one no no not quindi one King h2
you need the Queen on the two to secure
this important C 3 and d 4 squares you
need to secure those squares what lads
yeah he's suggesting this move but that
just losing endgame you know push check
the rook is on the wrong square you know
yeah this this endgame is you put the
rook behind it and that's a win
ok I mean then my King comes in slowly
win this all right how did Nakamura
force the draw here yes excellent Bravo
yes Bravo now if it takes now he will
simply go check here take the rock again
to do well in this Olympiad you also
have to hold the bad positions losing
it's not an option if you become if you
want to become a champion two years ago
when China won they only lost one game
imagine they played 11 rounds four
boards you know so that's like a lot of
games they played they only lost a
single game value one of the top board
lost just one game other guys didn't
lose a single game so so far not going
to would we're doing well we have no
losses in six rounds so that's like a
lot of games already played so US has no
losses some of the guys are doing really
well some guys are doing alright also
the same thing is for Indian team
they've got no losses they're playing
exceptionally well some of the guys are
just doing like winning a lot of games
so we'll talk about that let's finish
this game we'll talk about tomorrow's
matchups so check and take that straw so
far Mario well check check this looks
super scary I mean King is going to go
on f6 I mean but somehow there's no way
to win the rook or do anything so check
he comes back
check you didn't want to repeat because
at this point he realized his teammate
is worse so you went back here
threatening rook f3 check now what is
the key defense here for Nakamura what
is the key defense for him yes
rook f4 Bravo yes Bravo good defense
stopping rook after check and creating
your own threats check kg 5 not afraid
not afraid to go - I mean it's tricky
because there were some checks and
things you know you have to calculate
but he just calculated all and knew that
didn't work again check again I'm
telling you not too many strong
grandmasters would go like this it's
it's not easy you know to do this he
just calculated like a machine you know
that this all all this stuff doesn't
work doesn't do anything it's queen c5
check rook f5 now and the game ended
here I think with a draw think we need 3
or something
so now king can go back as well between
three end and now just make sure you
don't blow that tree for issue just get
back get back to the safety so on a
board three vastly slow didn't put too
much pressure it was a draw against
Grandmaster creeper Richelieu and same
Shanklin was very slightly worse against
Korra both he held a draw so twin half
and half tomorrow we're playing India
and we kind of know the Indians align up
because their reserve player is this
very young guys strong player 25 25 30
they play but he only played two games
the first two matches when they play
relatively weak teams so it's pretty
clear they're not going to put him on
this matchup so US team clearly knows
who they're going to face on each board
it's going to be hard Krishna top board
second is audubon who's been playing
really well and their third board is at
clinics
he has five and a half out of six Sanjay
you know who Jerry very young guy and
the third photo is said to Ramon so we
you know of course us Tim is going to go
with the top three guys got on a block
against how to krishna hopefully he can
just block it without too many
difficulties on the board too Hikaru is
white isn't try to press audubon and he
has defeated audubon recently I think in
Gibraltar or something in a very nice
game so he's a big favorite there and I
think us is going to try to put a lot of
pressure on that board on both two
against Audubon on the third board
Wesley is a much stronger player than
his opponent but his opponent is playing
really well in the young player so I
think Wesley should just maybe try to
neutralize him and if there are
opportunities go for the win on the
fourth board we have an advantage set to
Ramon won two games he's been very solid
but I think either Ray Robson or SEM
shun Khan whoever they put on should try
to press and hopefully try to get some
kind of advantage but again it's very
important to play careful and not to
lose any games because you lose one game
and you don't win any others that's it
you get no points it's not a game point
it's a match point you know before
Olympia is when you get game points
let's say you win 4-0 you get four
points you win two and a half you get
two and a half points the other team
gets one and half points but this way if
you lose one and a half to two and a
half it's a pretty bad result because
you get zero points so that's why you
really the margin of error is very small
I mean us is doing great but there are
still a lot of big teams they need to
face even if they win tomorrow it
doesn't win we can celebrate the gold
yet because we still have to play Russia
who are coming back after losing to
Ukraine they want two matches in a row
they defeated Germany convincingly today
three two one you got China who won
pretty you know they won against
Argentina two and half one and half
there are some other strong teams still
left
Netherlands Azerbaijan possibly so
they're still going to be a lot of
strong team
the US will potentially face but
tomorrow is the big test
currently us is sitting clear second
with 11 points out of 12 and the only
team with a perfect score is India and
again as I mentioned both teams haven't
suffered a single loss in the individual
games so tomorrow will basically show
you know how you know tomorrow result
will be really big today result was very
important to more exam more important
because the u.s. beats India they will
surpass them they will be cleared first
and then other teams will be chasing us
so the games will start at 6 a.m.
Central Time so by around two and a half
hour mark you can already see where
things stand okay all right so crucial
matchup tomorrow so make sure you watch
and cheer for the US team okay all right
now time for study is excellent very
good let's do some good studies okay
very famous I mean this is like very
very famous position white to play and
draw okay it doesn't look like everybody
know here so let's give a chance
everybody to know this position white to
play and draw it looks hopeless totally
hopeless you cannot stop my pond
I've got your stop I can stop your pond
so it looks like I'm gonna take this guy
you're not going to stop this one and I
win yes correct more confidence correct
now he's gonna push it looks like he's
just simply going to push the pond push
and win it now
it looks like we're just way behind as
postpone and the race is over now
continue continue playing creatively
here
it was a very famous study actually
this position is ready yes correct Wow
very good knowledge ready 1921 okay
what's the next move any ideas the next
book could be here yes King f6 correct
now if I continue pushing my pawn now
you Quinn King g7 push threaten to Queen
with a check and boom you get a queen so
it's a draw okay so when you can have
six I have to actually play king b6 and
secure the pawn win your pawn and then
push my passed pawn to get the victory
and now this is a special move that is
going to give you the draw this
particular move is very important that
you find and ammo is
yes what's the move Kinki five perfect
now you threatening to catch the pass
pawn if he takes your pawn you catch him
that's it
draw so he has to push if he wants to
win he has to push and now what do you
do
King d6 correct now it's funny you came
here and now you're going there
h2 continued he goes here perfect
he Queens and you quit and check when
you win okay alright now we'll sorry to
drop that's the idea okay so remember
that the only way to win in the
hopelessly looking position you need to
come to the center first to try to catch
them and then you have to you have to
create the threat of promoting your own
pants so once again you go King here
h4 King f6 it looks like we're losing he
has to go here otherwise you go King is
7 promote the pawn and you just catch it
okay
alright that's the way to do it
otherwise you just if it pushes qd6 and
Queen okay so remember that idea don't
don't resign if you see a similar
position that you think oh I cannot stop
the past pawn I should resign
don't resign if you have a passed pawn
that means you still have ideas okay you
still have some ideas to win it okay
okay now let's get one more for you
white to play and win okay and you have
to calculate six moves deep to find a
solution okay
six moves deep to Windows okay so your
first one is obvious right you're not
going to be able o we have another we
have somebody raising their hand already
six moves did you calculate everything
skewer excellent looks like she's got it
let's see the answer okay go ahead first
move three four so he's going to use the
same method right a five king c3 ah one
mistake one in accuracy and you're not
winning this a six you don't win I got
here draw King g3 she says and here
isn't this the same position it's just
reversed reversed here same exact
position as the previous passerby rated
all right Kim Ji Won brilliant yes
threatening to walking f2 so if it goes
King do too now you just simply go King
f2 perfect so now he will have to go
King before because now he is trying to
do this a six King III King f1 who say
day seven who say day seven III and now
f2 f1 draw block it first don't be in
hurry block it okay correct
now the next idea is if I play the move
King c4 why is this losing a six obvious
a7 a8 right a8 and now you Quinn and now
what is the final idea Queen a six check
and winning the Queen excellent
okay you have to know these studies this
King and palm positions are very very
important okay so it's end up with the
skewer and shish kabob shish kabob
tactic they call it here sometimes so
that's the idea to remember okay so did
everybody here understand the importance
of this two different positions because
here see this move here King G 1 is the
double exclamation mark that you need to
find if you don't find things you want
you're not going to win this
okay so you have to find the Kings you
want move in order to win it all right
because otherwise King g3 will simply
result in to which position position by
ready right this is the this is the
position by Radia kindy for draws so but
Kim Ji Won wins because now if he goes
can you three King FQ and here again you
simply go King here to stop at first and
here and which move is important to play
here can get one without rushing it okay
all right and if he starts with King c-4
what do we do a six looks like he is
going to clean it
a 7a and checkmate all right excellent
again yes exactly the King position but
that makes a whole lot of difference
another one is a draw this one is the
winner for white so little adjustment
makes a big difference okay great
again there are five more rounds to go
until the end of the Olympiad
follow this event it's every two years
it's a very big event everybody's
playing Marcus cross and strengths all
the best players are there fighting in
it so let's see how the US team will do
okay thanks everybody for coming tonight
then see you next time
you
you